we've come far enough through continuous
random variables that it is a good point
to just start pause and look back a
little bit and that will actually help
us move forward with today's content so
let's see how we can go in terms of all
of the concepts and skills that we have
covered so far in like the last couple
of weeks think back to the very first
lesson in this topic we had a look at we
compared the statistics we did earlier
in the year versus the statistics that
we would spend this chunk of time on
right what was the key difference
between the old statistics we were
looking at and the new ones a key very
good so we called them discrete random
variables right and that's where you've
got you know things that you count like
numbers of people or dollars things that
are separated out versus discrete versus
continuous random variables and this is
what we have spent our timer but we
needed to sort of point out that there
are some real differences between them
okay good so we looked at that and then
we said with these continuous random
variables that we would describe them in
terms of the language we've had in like
calculus land right we would use a
particular kind of function to describe
the chance of different outcomes and I
continue to random arrow what kind of
function was that Court has a
probability density function well does
so very good on these continuous random
variables we said okay the name of the
game is these particular functions here
and we looked at their properties namely
two of them what are the two properties
that every probability density function
has number one it all if you add up the
area underneath it equals one and then
there's the other one which we don't
look at very much but yeah the
probabilities have to be positive right
or zeros fine but you're kind of
negative probabilities okay we'll come
back to this guy in a second we then
have a look at the simplest kind of
probability density function the very
simple kind started with a you
we call them uniform probability
distributions and then of course all the
rest of them that are not uniform so we
looked briefly at that and then we've
spent most of our time I'm working with
all these probability density functions
and using them to find different things
so for example we might use the
probability density function as the name
suggest to find out a probability right
you'd go to the function you'd integrate
from whatever lower boundary to whatever
upper boundary and that would give you a
probability what other stuff can we find
with the probability density function
I'll give you a clue they all start with
M ok very good so so we call these
measures of central tendency very good
and they all start with M so we had our
first one the easiest one was the mode
that's just the highest point on your
probe a density function yeah
and then we said median what's the mean
how do we find the median on a
probability density function it's the
middle right so half of your scores or
whatever are in one side of the median
are from the other and then the the most
recent we did was main what we also call
me average in this context start with a
we call it expected value right so it
gets this different name in a
probability density a probability
distribution I should say on one more
thing just because it's on the board
what what are our abbreviations for
median and mean what are the okay so we
do use x-bar sometimes but more
frequently we've been using another
Greek letter so it's like a you with an
extra bit on it then think it's it's mu
right its mu mu and then what that
median median
okay so we're coming to I'll come to
that in a second we generally use q2
which is a bit weird right you're like
meaning why is it q2 it's actually
there's a good reason for what's the Q
stand for
it's the quartile and it's the second
one right okay um I left off one set of
brackets here right from from these guys
sorry
well you guys have done a lot of work
right we would then say okay you know
where the mean is you know where the
mean is now I want to know what's like
how much do you spread out from the mean
remember this okay
so we said from these there's this big
idea of variance from which you can also
get you all seen this to me before from
which you can also get standard
deviation and that standard deviation is
why we use Sigma s fur standard okay
so this is where we have been so far
just what I want you to notice is as you
look at all of these different concepts
I want you to notice how frequently to
work out any of these things how
frequently we need to take this
probability density function and then
basically we integrate right like do you
notice like every second question or or
more frequently actually you're like Oh
take it and then integrate take it and
integrate there's probably one notable
exception which is this guy the mode I'm
you know how we're looking for the
highest point on the probability density
function you're looking for the maximum
of this
so instead integrating you might
differentiate or you might just look at
the end points okay but for everything
else pretty much we are integrating okay
which is why the process of integrating
this guy
the probability density function when
you integrate it because this hop camp
camp happens comes up and happens so
frequently it gets its own name and
that's the first concept we're going to
have a look at today so the heading you
can make is cumulative distribution
[Applause]
close function if you integrate a
function you're going to get another
function right so this is called the
d/f PDF integrates up into the CDA so
this is our this is our heading for
today
okay now let's uh before we start
looking at like the notation for it I
want us to understand what on earth it
means so firstly I've told you it's
basically what happens when you take
your density function and then you
integrate but I want to understand the
name like what's what's this about okay
cumulative so let's think about
frequency which is a an idea we got from
our discrete random variables versus
cumulative frequency because this is
where we usually use the word cumulative
right okay so I'm sorry I keep doing
this to you but it's just an easy
example that I think you can all attach
to let's think one more time about
Heights in this class okay
so I might say what is the frequency I
know sorry Zacky I'll pick a different
height this time um what's the frequency
of max how tall are you
can you tell us your actual height you
know 190 far okay so 590 right so if I
asked stay with me atop what is the
frequency frequency of heights of 190
centimeters or kind of like a hundred
and ninety right in this class and the
answer would be one right that would be
the frequency but if I asked what's the
cumulative frequency of that same height
what that would mean is I include that
height but then I also include everyone
before that right does that make sense
so we we accumulate so in this class
that would be oh is that twenty this no
nineteen twenty today what is it today
today six okay so you can see what that
does is it includes Max's height and
everyone beneath Max's high right well
before okay so you accumulate everything
so now I want you to think about what
that might mean here okay so what is the
probability density function give you it
gives you a probability right of a
certain event
taking on a certain value by the way um
we've talked we've used this notation
before but I remember I think it's
germane actually asked me this question
she's like what's with the big X and the
little X so if this is something that's
just gone over your head this is as good
a point as any to highlight what it
means that big X is what thing are you
interested in measuring right now what's
what's the variable okay so in the
example that I just gave you its height
but it might be temperature or it might
be population size or something like
that okay so this is what's the actual
variable being measured and then this
guy over here the little X is what value
are you interested in that variable
taking for example 100 M 90 centimeters
that's a value the variable is like the
height okay so this gives us the
probability of a certain thing but if I
must say okay in a cumulative way I'm
now asking not what's the probability of
a certain one thing happening but what
is the probability of that thing
happening or any height less than that
remember that so how would I know take
this well it's it's anything less than
or equal to that particular number that
you're interested in that particular
value so make sense and that'll be the
little X okay so there's the value
there's the variable okay so what we do
is we say this is our definition okay
our cumulative distribution function is
or equals rather the probability of
being less than some certain thing okay
now you might remember when we were
first introduced to probability density
functions we don't like having these
one-sided inequalities because when
we're integrating because that's that's
what we're going to do eventually you've
got to start somewhere you got to end
somewhere does that make sense right so
instead of saying it this way what we'll
do is we'll say you start from wherever
wherever your values start your lowest
height your lowest temperature we
generally call that what the lowest
thing is it zero I mean sometimes it's
zero but we generally use a 1/3 like
beginning right do I go from A to B A to
B so I'll start at a
and then I will go up to and include
whatever value you're interested in
right now does that make sense okay yeah
yes that's exactly what it is but but in
a specific like for acidity value yeah
exactly
okay now once you get to here I just put
your pens now for a second because I'm
going to show you something
to not write which is that weird I do so
pens now once you've gotten to this
point okay now we normally are pretty
okay with writing the integral that
comes from here we would normally say
you integrate from start to end like so
and then we would normally say oh well
you're integrating the probability
density function which we usually call
what like what's the typical name of it
it's just f of X right so don't write
this place you would normally say
putting in your probability density
function and then integrate okay and the
reason I'm telling you not to write this
is I wonder if you notice something kind
of peculiar about what I've just written
you integrate this thing with X and then
once you've got a primitive you then put
your lower and upper boundaries in right
yes I know I know but you're going to
acute it from the start to whatever
value you're interested in okay but but
this is the thing which is weird right
you're like wait a second you're
integrating with respect to X but then
the thing you put in is X that's a
little bit weird right so now this is
what I would like you to write instead
of writing f of X DX
we write f of T DT now this is a very
minor difference in the end we basically
do the same thing and I'm gonna give you
an example in a second right whatever
your probability density function is you
just pop it in integrate it and then
substitute in your a and your X but just
as a point of formal notation we don't
like putting X into X so we just give
this a different name okay